6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil.
And I'm Georgie. That's one small step for man, one giant leap for mankind. Famous words.
But do you know who said them? Of course, that was Neil Armstrong, the first person to land
on the moon. Right. The Apollo 11 spacecraft landed Neil
Armstrong on the moon on 20th July 1969. But in decades after that famous event,
interest in returning to the moon faded away. Until now.
Summer 2023 saw the start of a new race for the moon between Russia's Lunar 25 spacecraft
and India's Chandrayan 3. Russia's rocket crashed on landing, but Chandrayan 3 successfully
touched down on the 23rd of August, making India only the fourth country to successfully
land on the moon. But why this sudden interest in going back to the moon? That's what we'll
be discussing in this programme, and as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary
too. But before we blast off, I have a question for you, Georgie. Everyone knows that Neil Armstrong
was the first man on the moon and was followed by a second astronaut Buzz Aldrin. But who
was the third Apollo astronaut who flew the command module while his crewmates walked
on the moon? Was it a Yuri Gagarin, b Michael Collins or C. Allen Sheppard?
Hmm, I think it was Michael Collins.
Okay, Georgie, we'll find out the answer at the end of the programme.
In some ways, the current interest in the moon is really more about the origins of Earth.
One theory is that during the early days of the solar system, around four billion years
ago, another planet crashed into Earth, breaking off a part, which then formed the moon. Unlike
the Earth's surface, which is constantly moving, the moon is completely still, frozen in time
to create a perfectly preserved record of what happened at the birth of the solar system.
Here's astronomer Dr. Becky Smithhurst explaining more to BBC Radio 4 programme Inside Science.
Whereas on the moon, it's just this inert rock. There's no atmosphere. So every single
thing that's happened to the moon in its four and a half billion years worth of history
is still recorded there on it. So if anyone's ever seen an image of the far side of the moon,
the side of the moon that we cannot see from Earth is incredibly pop-up. There are
craters all over that thing. And so this is a really big deal when we're thinking about
what happened to the early Earth as well, because we think all of the Earth's water came
from impacts with comets and asteroids in the very early days of the solar system.
The rock which makes up the moon is inert. It doesn't move. It's also full of craters,
which holes in the ground caused by something hitting it. The moon has so many of these
craters, it's described as pockmarked, having a surface that's covered in small marks and scars.
These craters play an important part in the story. Because the moon's surface does not
change, finding water there would explain a lot about how water and therefore life started
on Earth. That's why Dr. Smithhurst calls the moon mission a big deal, meaning important
or significant. That's right. Astronomers know that comets are full of ice and think
comets brought water to Earth when they crashed into it. Evidence of those crashes has been
erased by the constantly moving surfaces on Earth, but not on the moon. So comparing
water from the moon with water on Earth could provide scientists with vital information
as Dr. Smithhurst explained to BBC Radio 4's Inside Science.
Yeah, so they'll be looking essentially to see if it has the same characteristics as water
here on Earth. And then we can sort of trace that back from sort of the crater history as
well to working out what actually happened, how long has it been there for as well? Also
various other minerals that might be there, these very heavy minerals that we know come
from comets and asteroids. Again, that'll be this sort of smoking gun to be like, yes,
that's where this water came from. And it's likely that Earth's water came from there as
well.
Scientists can trace the existence of water on the moon back to find out what happened
on Earth. If you trace something back, you discover the causes of something by investigating
how it developed.
For this reason, Dr. Smithhurst says finding water on the moon would be finding a smoking
gun, a modern idiom meaning indisputable evidence or proof. We've learned a lot about
the moon, but we still don't know the answer to your question, Neil, who was the third
Apollo astronaut on that famous first landing in 1969? I said it was Michael Collins, which
was the correct answer. Michael Collins never set foot on the moon himself, but afterwards
said the experience of looking back at Earth from the Apollo spacecraft changed his life
forever.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from our trip to the moon, starting with
inert, not moving or unable to move. A crater is a very large hole in the ground.
Pockmarked means marked by small holes and scars. If you say something is a big deal, it's
important or significant in some way. To trace something back means to discover its causes
by examining how it developed.
And finally, the idiom as smoking gun refers to indisputable evidence or conclusive proof
of something. Once again, our six minutes are up. Join us next time for more scintillating
science and useful vocabulary here at six minute English. Goodbye for now.
Goodbye.